is there um
let's put on your wise
visionary hat and ask um when you look
to young folks is there advice you can
give
to young people today whether in high
school or college
about career about life
you've lived quite a non-linear and
fascinating life yourself
is there advice you can give either on
career or more generally in life
well i i would say what what people
often hear
is that um you know
we're not actually here for that long a
period of time
um and so to the a and the world
is on fire and whether humanity survives
is not clear and whether how many uh
species are we gonna kill before we
figure out not to do that anymore
so i would advise you to really try to
develop a combination of what do you
need in terms of
income for your own survival but what
does the world need in terms of
helped to make the world better and you
know um
howard thurman who he talked about who
who ran the good friday experiment the
minister there he said
he's got a famous quote attributed to
him he says um
[Music]
and this is exactly it's a young people
he said um
you know there's nothing particular that
you should do but find what makes you
come alive because what the world needs
is people that have come alive
and are passionate um so
i i would say that um
beware of this uh
trap that you need um vast resources
that you need all this stuff
you know uh you know i i keep thinking
of the um
super wealthy people in first class on
the titanic
you know as the titanic is sinking you
know their money's not going to help
them
the the earth is like titanic you know
we're sinking we're destroying the
planets destroying the environment so
it's you need a certain amount of money
to be comfortable
uh to not be at that edge of survival
because once you're at that edge of
survival it's hard to think about
anything else
but but i'd say to young people um
to the extent that you're able to do
this and again student debt and all this
kind of stuff is a big problem there too
but um really just try to
find this combination of what the world
needs and what you need the the other
thing
to say to young people is um life is a
lot shorter than you think
that and a 20-year plan is not really
that long
so if it takes you 20 years to get in a
position to do what you want to do
go for it you know have long term plans
the the other part
that was so important for me to um
keep doing what i've been doing
basically now it's
49 years that i've sort of been devoting
my life on psychedelics since i was 18.
um when i started i didn't think it
would ever work i just thought this is
the only idea i have in this crazy world
you know this is what i want to work on
luckily i had support from my family
that took care of my survival needs
so i could do that but i realized that
if my
happiness was dependent upon
accomplishments
that i might never be happy that i was
able to
reframe happiness in terms of effort
you know so if i'm trying hard to get
stuff
to be better whether it's better or not
i can be happy at the end of each day
i tried and so i think you you try to
separate out
the goals that you have and your
happiness to whether you're trying hard
um the other thing i would say is that
um
everybody has this humanity within them
so be very careful about dividing the
world into us and them
um you know and try to
so so one of the things that i've done
um
that has um taken a long time because
you know i feel like um
you know drugs are illegal i always felt
like you know the police were the
predator and i'm the prey
yes you know but now we're working with
the police and the police have
tremendous trauma from the work that
they do
we have one police officer who is now
going he's a full-time police officer
he's also a psychotherapist and he's
going through our training program
to learn how to give mdma therapy to
other police officers
and i met his police chief a couple
times he got permission from his police
chief to go to the second part of our
training program which is where we give
mdma to therapists who volunteer
as a patient so we have just a couple
weeks ago
dosed the police with mdma yeah and
so i think this idea of those people
that are on the quote other side
try to see through that to their
humanity
to what their pains and suffering what
their struggles are to the extent that
you can
and um that i think and and build
long-term relationships you
you never know what's gonna um come
around 20 years from now so you help
some people try to keep these
relationships going 20 years from now
something could
could come and um and
also um be persistent
you know yeah i think that's
that's been the key to success i mean
once the fda or dea figured out
we're not going anywhere they're going
to have to deal with us
then we started getting some progress
it's a mix of patience and stubbornness
that gets things done
you